Across the globe,...
...people are choosing to have fewer children or none at all.
Governments are desperate to halt the trend,...
...but their influence seems to stop at the bedroom door.
Are some societies destined to become extinct? Hardly.
However, birth rates are falling far below replacement levels in China,...
...Japan, Singapore, and South Korea.
And after five decades of industrialization, Korea,...
...a mostly rural country with six births per woman during its civil war in the 1950s,...
...now has 1.08 births per woman.
Korea's birthrate is the lowest in the 30 - member OECD...
...and the birthrate has fallen to its lowest level on record in 2005,...
...sparking concern about our shrinking population and aging society.
Due to dwindling births, Korea's population...
...which stands at 48 million this year,...
...is forecast to fall to 40 million in 2050.
Hong Kong has the world's lowest birthrate...
...at 0.95 per woman of childbearing age.
But, if the trend in Korea continues,...
...birth rates will approach or dip even lower than those of Hong Kong.
The National Statistics Office...
...has said that more women were putting off marriage to a later age,...
...with many reluctant to have children.
Despite incentives from the government to boost the birthrate,...
...young Koreans regard children...
...as an expensive burden on their lifestyles and careers.